going to be in washington and stay in
washington for now where the
democratic-led house voted last night to
punish newly elected republican
congresswoman
marjorie taylor-green for endorsing
false conspiracy theories in the past
green told the house she now rejects the
claim that school shootings like the one
in parkland florida
were staged and the 9 11 attacks never
happened
chris van cleave is on capitol hill for
us chris good morning to you
how did green's fellow republicans
respond
well good morning 11 republicans that's
one more than the number that voted to
impeach former president trump a month
ago voted
with democrats to strip congresswoman
greene
of her two committees the education
committee and the budget committee that
included
three republicans from south florida now
greene
had a cast doubt on whether or not the
parkland shooting had happened in one of
the conspiracy theories
she has spread that clearly was a factor
in those votes
this as the bulk of the republican party
backed green as that party now has to
figure out its way forward
the yeas are 230 and the nays are 199.
the resolution is adopted in a mostly
party line vote the house stripped
georgia republican marjorie taylor green
from her committee assignments i will be
protecting freedom of speech
greene who previously spread hateful and
violent conspiracy
theories mrs green tried thursday to
walk back her controversial comments
see school shootings are absolutely real
i also want to tell you 9 11
absolutely happened i remember that day
crying all day long watching it on the
news
but for democrats it was too little too
late we are dealing with conduct that
brings
shame on this house this is not about
party
it's about whether or not you will vote
for decency
and truth while many republicans
disavowed her comments they argued the
opposition
removing a member from committees could
now be on the table when republicans
take power
everyone has said things they wish they
didn't say everyone has done things they
wish they didn't do
so who's next following the vote
alexandria ocasio-cortez
took to the floor for an hour with
fellow lawmakers to share personal
accounts from the capital siege
29 days ago the glass
in and around this very chamber was
shattered by gunshots
clubs by individuals seeking to restrain
and murder members of congress duly
elected to carry out the duties
of their office michigan's rashida talib
broke down in tears while describing how
she fears for her staff's safety
and i worry every day for their lives
because of this rhetoric i never thought
that they would feel unsafe here
and as that debate was raging up here on
the hill
house democrats surprised many here with
a request
for former president trump to testify at
his impeachment trial next week
in the senate the former president's
legal team called that a public
relations stunt and said mr trump will
not be testifying
democrats say that could be used in the
trial as an
example of how the president has not
taken responsibility
tony all right chris thank you very much